kristina is with us in Nevada to start
off this hour hi Christina how are you
hello how are you
better than I deserve what's up alright
so bear with me I can see why people get
kind of nervous we just found you last
week and my husband and I are looking at
you know getting out of debt and living
better lives um we currently have three
teenagers at home two of which are over
the age of 18 and they do and one of
them's not biologically ours we took in
my daughter's fiance when his mom moved
across the country and so they both pay
rent and this is where my husband and I
are bouncing heads of each other is
because I want to put the the rent that
kids pay towards our thousand dollars
and then after that put it towards
paying off any outstanding well a lot of
outstanding debt he wants to keep it out
and pay it and pay the monthly payments
which I don't see that being I mean
either way it washes out but I don't see
that being rational because we can keep
track of it and pay off that faster if
we use it towards the the debt and the
thousand-dollar emergency fund okay
regardless of work regardless of where
it comes from it's not kept out of
anything and it's not assigned to
anything your income all goes at the top
of the page all of your income
regardless of where it comes from okay
and that's then becomes one number at
the top of the page that you have to
spend this month they're going to take
all of that money that pile of money
that comes from various jobs rent coming
in whatever it is and you say alright
we're going to give every one of those
dollars an assignment and basically we
put the household on beans and rice rice
and beans scorched earth we save $1,000
is baby step one with any money we could
squeeze out of the budget after that
then we're going to list our debts
smallest to largest and we're going to
attack them in that order so if you're
going to use our system both of you are
wrong yes and that's he thinks I'm
trying to get him again just finding you
last week he's still thinking his
budgeting way which I pointed out
budgeting away is how we got into this
[Laughter]
didn't take you long to catch on so
here's what I'll do let me do this you
guys
the biggest thing let me tell you the
other thing that happens that that one
highest points of correlation with
success meaning if you do this you're
highly likely to be successful is the
two of you to get on the same page and
get aligned very few couples who are at
odds continually win with money it
almost never happens all of our all of
our data for 30 years shows that so I'm
gonna send you a copy of our book free
it's called the Total Money Makeover 7
million people have read it okay both of
you read it it's a book you it's a book
you can read in two nights okay I mean
like not staying up all night nights I
mean it's not that order look ok so um a
lot of pictures in it so yeah both of
you read it and then both of you decide
we're going to do this or we're not
going to do this but if you're going to
do our plan the way you would do it is
you jump on every dollar calm and you
download our free budgeting app so now
you got two free things in this
conversation
our free budgeting app and you would
just yesterday hope not swear I was
that's why I was arguing with him so you
know we're gonna do this first this
second he just you know again well
you've got to pee a little bit of
information about our stuff that he
doesn't have and so let's just catch him
up with the information and I think
that'll create alignment rather than
arguing about he's not smart because his
plan didn't list or something that's
funny and it's true but it's probably
not a point of persuasion right so okay
so where are these kids moving out and
so they actually just got engaged there
they just got their first job since last
year and there's much as they can right
now old of it
for them to move out with a nest egg and
so they're actually jumping also as a
family this coming Friday we are going
to be purchasing your SP you because
it's either that or put it on a credit
card and I went no we're gonna pay for
it with cash okay so
this coming Friday is that close as soon
as we can purchase it and so they are
going to get their own subscription as
well because they're you know it's going
to be a couple together but they
couldn't have a job on it with not
having so far so how old are they
exactly 18 19 and when are they getting
married not for at least two years
they've already made that plan together
they want to save and pay for the
wedding in cash and also be able to
afford their place their own apartment
okay and how much do they earn currently
my daughter makes approximately twenty
thirty sixteen hundred a month
he makes approximately eighteen hundred
a month I'm gonna want to move up their
timeline on everything okay but well but
we'll let them decide that after they
have new information as well with
Financial Peace University because I
think I think they're making enough
money with no overhead don't mount
anything that they can go ahead and get
married if they want to have some kind
of celebration later that's fine and the
then they can you know that when they
get out and get on their own and get
their own dignity it's gonna change your
whole lot of stuff and it'll probably
change the dynamics in your household in
a good way even though you'll be a
thousand dollars of money yeah Porter
okay but not quite because you're paying
for a lot of stuff but yeah so we're
gonna put both of you guys through
Financial Peace University as my guest
instead you know instead of giving you
the book okay and we'll just make that
our wedding gift to them now here's the
thing to understand okay some
interesting data out there called the
poverty sequence and this is what I'm
worried about with this couple so I want
to make sure we get all this right if
you graduate from high school then get
married then have babies and and you
don't live together before you're
getting married
mmm-hmm so if they move out and shack up
they're violating this sequence right
they increase their probability of
living above
if you do the things in the order the
old-fashioned order so to speak okay and
there's all kinds of data on this that
are out there a lot of several studies
that are backing this up but the most
interesting one is if you graduate from
high school before you get married and
you get married before you have children
and you don't move in together before
you get married you have a 97%
probability of never living below the
poverty level
isn't that interesting
and so that that's what I'm trying to
protect here and trying to inject myself
into this discussion with these young
kids so you got you guys hold on and
we'll have a Kelly pickup we'll get you
both signed up for Financial Peace
University and let's see if we can get
these kids off on the right foot and get
you and your husband turned around and
aligned together and working together
and then we're gonna have a whole lot of
winners in this conversation